let's say that we have capital f of x as
being equal to the definite integral
from pi to x of cotangent squared of t
dt and what we're curious about finding
is the derivative of this business we
want to figure out what f prime
what f prime of x is equal to
well this is a direct application of the
fundamental theorem of calculus this is
just going to be the derivative with
respect to x of all of this craziness so
let me just copy and paste that
so copy and paste so it's just going to
be the derivative with respect to that
and the fundamental theorem of calculus
tells us that this is going to be equal
to
this is going to be equal to just this
function this function but it's not
going to be a function of t anymore it's
going to be a function it's going to be
a function of x so it's going to be
equal to cotangent
squared of x and you'll often see
problems like this if you go to calculus
competitions or things like that and or
maybe certain exams it's like oh my god
i have to take the anti-derivative of
all of this business evaluate it at the
different boundaries and then i got to
take the derivative no you just applied
the fundamental theorem of calculus it's
actually a very straightforward and a
very fast thing to do
now let's mix it up a little bit
let's say that you had the expression
the definite integral from pi instead of
from pi to x let's say it's from pi to x
squared let me write that x squared in a
different color just to make it clear
what i'm doing from pi
to x squared
x squared of
cotangent cotangent squared of t
dt and you wanted to take the derivative
of this business so you want to take the
derivative with respect to x you want to
take the derivative with respect to x of
this business how would you do it
well the recognition here is is that
this is capital capital f of x was
defined as this now instead of an x you
have an x squared so this is the exact
same thing as taking the derivative with
respect to x of
capital f of
capital f of not x that would be this
instead we have capital f of x squared
where we had an x here before we now
have an x squared we now have an x
squared you can verify if you had
capital f of x squared every place where
you saw the x here would be an x squared
so it would look exactly like this
and so we just have to apply the chain
rule so this is going to be equal to and
this is going to be equal to the
derivative
the derivative of f with respect to x
squared so it's going to be this is just
straight out of the chain rule it's
going to be f prime
of
x squared
of x squared
times the derivative
of the derivative with respect to x of x
squared this is the derivative of f with
respect to x squared and then times the
derivative of x squared with respect to
x this is just the chain rule right over
here
so what's f prime of x squared the
derivative of f with respect to x
squared
well if you evaluated f prime at x
squared instead of just being cotangent
squared of x it's going to be cotangent
squared of x squared so this part right
over here this business right over here
is going to be cotangent
squared of x squared
of x squared so this is the derivative
of all of this business with respect to
x squared and then you have to multiply
that you have to multiply that times the
derivative of x squared with respect to
x which is just 2x so there you have it
the derivative of this all this
craziness is equal to 2x cotangent
squared of x squared